Bert just got a check from all things
comedy this is the first checkup they've
said they've given me checks in the past
that goes to my business manager but he
gave me this one and I've never looked
at a check I've gotten from them yeah
now you share an advertising revenue is
that how it works
yeah it's like a pool you guys are I'm
not really certain our business model to
be dead honest with you and I do have
all I have something's burning and my
podcast with bill burr yeah so I thought
I'd let you look at the check first all
right this is gonna I was gonna try to
guess how much it is based on because I
thought I'd check and eyes go well
that's half of it I'll see half that
money right you're to Z goes to
manager's name yeah no no and this goes
straight to Bert this goes straight to
Bert yeah all right so let's say it's a
respectable amount for real it's not a
bad amount yeah keep it in yeah well I
get I get residual checks for MADtv 27
years later for two cents for real yeah
five cents I've heard MADtv come up so
much lately yeah someone was talking
about it on a podcast the other day they
were like oh yeah did you know Adam Ray
was on MADtv he was not he was on a vive
oh let's be less common but the last
about 15 minutes that I love Adam Ray
yeah and towns a guy but look at me
don't ever say that again
now I got what I cuz the Goldbergs I
would always show up and I've been doing
it for you know six years and you know I
would do it and they paid me well toward
the end because I would they wanted me
as a recurring but I became you know
part of the show a little bit and so uh
I didn't realize that I got a check and
my business manager was like hey good
news and it was a check check and I went
huh what do you mean and well the
Goldberg place in 32 countries all over
the world and it plays 30 times today
this is where you start making that
money this is
vote money you know what I mean this is
not yet but good money I appreciate that
maybe maybe but it's good to buy a boat
yeah not the one anyone's gonna ride it
but I did a campaign for a thing and and
it's for gambling in a little bit and I
felt a little bit like I call my father
and I go I go I might as well my soul I
don't know I feel about this he said
you're providing what the marketplace
wants gambling on sports is legal now I
know I know and I and I understand that
and and I told him how much I'm and he
goes yeah you'll get over it [ __ ] your
problems my dad's mantra he [ __ ] in cash
checks shut up dude you actually a
classy company it's actually a really
classy it's a it's a it's a classic I
got approached by one of the people who
sells a vape pen for nicotine and
they're like would you be interested in
that I was like yeah when my starts a
book yeah how many kids died what what
do we code their lungs a [ __ ] that's
just that I get scared of oh dude I
I remember being I remember taking him
everyone I remember on it to be the
first company that was like will send
you product check it out tell us what
you think right this is right well we
all got podcast and I remember taking
[ __ ] alpha brain and my wife throwing
it away because I was so [ __ ] amped
up oh really
I remember going on Rogan he's like did
you take it and I go I [ __ ] love it
my wife took it away from he and I had
the craziest [ __ ] dreams that night
Wow and I to this day like alpha brain
is something that my wife that 5-htp
works legit but for every one of those
you get some [ __ ] thing we were like
yeah some response were you're like oh I
do on it's the only supplement company
I'll go with because they're MCT oil is
great but I just because I know rogue he
takes it and I know Rogen's you cannot
listen to Joe how much to take no we did
this funk streamis the cyborg if you
take his face off there's his propellers
and wire we did we did that much
attention being on all eight he smoked
weed and got more success
yeah well we did the podcast where they
talked about re dosing me and I was
still having problems with my serotonin
levels there was it was [ __ ] up for a
while but it was like though it was the
like three days after it happened and I
still was having hardcore panic attacks
and I wasn't right yet and just like
just take a little love new mood and I
was like and I know that stuff works and
I was like you have somebody's account
right here and he opened up my mom and
he's like take four maybe six four six
you're a bigot so I take four and then
he goes re goes I might take somebody
gives it to Arion or he's like it says
take two with a meal and Joe's a guy you
don't need that already put his back are
you dosed me and put his back in the
case because I'm gonna hold off that
night I'm sitting at home going I feel a
little [ __ ] aggressive like there's
too much serotonin going on I guess I
bet my cat but yeah I fight over petting
your call yeah I don't know man I'm
always afraid of everything I took one
here whatever we he smokes
I took one hit today I had to have Shaab
come and pick me up at the studio and
take me to his house I ate a steak I was
still high it took me six hours to be
able to get my car mmm I uh by the way
we have caught coyote Peterson coming
I'm so excited I got stung by a bee -
the other day oh you did yeah yeah you
know cut you know coyote I've been yard
I've been a famiiy is he was like the
first guy rose like I was like like you
know when you see like hot ones you saw
hot ones and you were like dad of course
that's gonna be great yeah right I'll
try to say like man vs. food
I saw a man vs. food and I was like of
course that's gonna be great a guy's
gotta eat all whole steak that's John
Candy and great out this is gonna be
awesome yeah coyote Peterson I think my
kids showed it to me oh here eh
how you doing we're talking about you
right now as we speak
come on in come on in I was talking I
was talking about how I discovered you
um let's get into some ads huh guys one
thing I enjoy doing is wearing ads now
reading ads now here's the thing my
favorite underwear in the world and I
bet you this one time I'm not wearing
them I'm wearing my Calvin's my favorite
underwear in the world I have so many
and this is no lie our me undies I swear
to God they hold you could probably wear
them
what they're made of module or something
some kind of a a natural fiber or
something that's three times softer than
cotton whatever I like the way they feel
they never ever stretch out they're
perfect on there the best time I've ever
had and I don't think anybody disagrees
I think Rogan agrees with this I think
he bought like he threw all the other
one underwear out there the best so me
Andes has the most adorable Valentine's
Day prints you can get lovey dovey this
year you can get it for women and men
meet undies it also makes buddy bands so
you can match with your your pet which
is honestly more important than people
and you can match with your girl or your
guy whatever so there you go you've got
you've got all kinds of rhyming ones
you've got that Valentine's Day one
you've got everything so by the way
here's another one they have the lounge
where rumor has it it's lounge where you
can we're out and about so how about
that you can wear your me undies on the
outside of your pants
they've got great offers here it is you
get 15% off and free shipping and I
guarantee they'll be the best underwear
you've ever had fact 50% off your first
pair free shipping and Al Harb said
satisfaction guarantee beyond these
dot-com slash fighter me undies dot-com
slash fighter best underwear in the
world you guys wonder why my hair is so
incredibly full and lush well I take
hims I take finasteride okay I take my
hair pills from hims if you have
erectile dysfunction which as you guys
know I'm a virile stud I don't have that
problem but they've got you there too
the fact is 40% of men by age 40
struggle with not being able to get and
maintain an erection it's just the way
it is your body starts to break down you
start to lose your hair they got you
they got your skinnies they got your
your erectile dysfunction needs and and
it's all science this is not this is not
gas station pills I when I got my hair
stuff for my hair finasteride I took a
picture of my hair in five minutes I
sent it to a real doctor in five minutes
I had my prescription in the mail so
it's the best and it's a lot cheaper I
used to go with you know brand stuff and
it cost me hundreds of dollars a month
and hims cost me a lot less it's one
stop shop for hair loss skin care sexual
wellness for men so there you go
prescription of solutions backed by
science you got all kinds of treatments
you you've don't know in doctor visits
that's what's the main amazing no
painful injections you answer like a
couple question about your medical
history chat with a doctor for
confidential review and you're off to
the races so there you go for hims
dot-com slash fighter Edie for hims
dot-com slash fighter ii d get your hair
back get your piece back come on let's
get to work prescription products are
subject to doctor approval okarin online
consultation with a physician that will
determine if prescription is appropriate
c website for full details and safety
information this could cost hundreds if
you want in person to the doctor's
office or pharmacy I promise you I've
done it I'm a client currently right now
for hims calm slash fighter IDI coyote
Peterson's in the house I was just
talking about how I found you and what
I'll share this with you because I think
it's a testament to how great everything
you've put out on all the content you
put out I think is I know you have a new
show I just saw it come up the other day
yeah is it where's it on brave the wild
it's on Animal Planet premieres February
9th I work for Animal Planet so long did
you really yeah I did I did I got three
pilot deal with them tonight Asin hey
you know what my show was I'm gonna find
the world's best dancing dog that sounds
like I said first night my fur this
business production talk my first night
we go to have like a little production
meeting with the director the producers
the writers everyone and I was like guys
and I'm like they're like you wanna be
or I was like no no no we had to work
tomorrow
and they're like yeah I wanna have a
beer and I was like guys want to be on
my my game I want to make sure this gets
picked up and this one guy I just called
Mike because I his name he goes really
and I want what he goes do you want to
spend the rest of your life looking for
dancing dogs or do you want to just
maybe gonna make an okay show hope it
doesn't get picked up and get paid know
what yeah I don't want to look for
dancing
because I have a [ __ ] beer and I was
like by the way I had the best time
shooting that show ever I would work
with those guys every dancing [ __ ]
dog and by the way we've met the expert
with the world's best dancing dog and it
was so lackluster or can't whisper the
whole show is about finding the best and
the expert the best dancing dog maybe it
was such a lackluster performance that
the cameramen were doubled over going
this is what we've been looking for
it was so [ __ ] bad we watched two
horses [ __ ] that day and that was way
more interesting what you tell me about
your show okay so the the new show
braved the wild so if you guys are
familiar with the YouTube content right
hundred [ __ ] percent so we captured a
grittiness right with what we were doing
for YouTube's fast-paced production but
I had enough television quality that
people were like what is this doing on
YouTube and not on television so we
basically took the concepts that were
being done with like planet earth that
style of cinematography drone shots high
quality camera footage slow-mo type
stuff merge that together with a brave
wilderness youtube channel so it's like
a baby between planet Earth and what
brave wilderness was to create this next
level of adventure see I'm coming down
dumb that down for me who already loves
you now are you still getting stung by
[ __ ] not intentionally okay no there's a
fair share of blood and accidents to
happen and before the first shoot of the
first season first night out on a
location Australia I'm bit in the face
by a nine-foot carpet python just that's
like they're using a lot of that geezers
who just got bit in the face by snake
people want to see that if he wasn't and
it wasn't provoked enough legit like him
holding it and just cook and it is so
you were holding a wild snake mm-hmm and
it and it was like and usually they're
not supposed to by the branch they're on
oh they're not usually supposed to bite
anything that isn't messing with them
but of course you know when you pick up
a 9 foot Python in the middle of the
Australian rainforest and it's like this
is not a normal part of my day and
there's all these lights it senses a
warm heat signature in front of it it's
thinking okay well you're bigger than
something I'd probably eat you must be a
predator I'm gonna bite you before you
bite me and maybe I'll put me down so
that's exactly what happened and I gave
the snake exactly the respect it asked
for
place right back in the environment
where like man that was 100 see where to
bite you on my upper lower lip so we
called being kissed by a Python I mean
full spread of its mouth and they have
razor-sharp teeth that are like
backwards turn razor blades so I'm
really lucky didn't grapple onto my lip
because getting that off would just open
me up big toe yeah a bit let go like
whoa yep and then you know my camera
team is so amazing because in most
instances people would freak out and be
like holy cow cut the cameras is he okay
my camera team knows that yes this is
the moment everybody's looking for they
keep rolling you you run with it in your
hands I didn't know there was a
rainforest in Australia three times that
I didn't know that I so there's a
rainforest yeah okay so now sort of like
temperate rainforests along like the
eastern coast from the top up on the top
by Cannes well like so Northern
Territory New South Wales like though
the whole stretch along the coastline
just a bit in from like the Sunshine
Coast is beautiful tropical forests well
running look at that did you have to get
like disinfected exactly uh no we just
threw a little saline solution on it and
kept filming like we weren't looking for
a carpet python we were searching after
something called a long-finned eel which
is this huge alien looking eel creature
I mean one of the top predators in the
river ecosystems there and how big can
grow up to like 10 feet in length what
yeah long-finned eel they mate what they
might in person they won't I mean if you
take them out of the water and you put
your hand in your mouth yeah can bite
you but they're super hard to catch very
elusive it took me eight hours before I
was able to finally get one so you can
you're in the water
mm-hmm now no Crocs no Crocs and where
are you for for this we're we're just
inside the Sunshine Coast okay you're
not up where the Crocs live no the Crocs
are further up into northern territories
so two types of crocodiles and we did a
huge crocodile episode freshwater
crocodiles and saltwater got here all
the salt waters with a bad one some
other Germans like crazy
I mean German sure
at such a quick clip in [ __ ]
Australia every sign is do not swim and
then it says nine swimming don't
crocodile I swear to God Germans die
like crazy because they've never
experienced anything they live in this
[ __ ] palm of a world where it's just
a black forest and the worst thing they
had were Jews got rid of them right
there like so hey this is crazy but I
don't know if this is mermans died at
such a rate quicker than anyone because
they have no egos if no tigers lions
crocodiles snakes nothing they've just
other Germans Tarantino [ __ ] Brian they
legit don't have Jewish people they're
legit don't have like there's none there
when you talk to a German go to what do
you say about your Jewish friend they go
I've never met one I swear to God so
when they go to Australia they're like
would endure these are must be really
nice to swim in this water in the
waterfall can't stop sex that's sick I
want stop for a second and I mean this
that's the best German action I've ever
heard of my life thank you Brian
that's so good hey are you German Anna
Laura go swimming and she's like under
girl game what's the word that's what
happened to are you speaking German ah
that's good English that's a good accent
Sherman's pull up the number of Germans
at dot Germans die everywhere bro there
was a period of Florida where Germans
were dying 10 at a time just out of the
airport they had to stop cause they're
getting robbed they were changed they'd
change the laws on license plates in
America for rental cars in Florida
they're getting because of Germans yes
or no no that's not co2 it's not a
coyote and I don't know what the [ __ ]
it's as bad as real as that terrible
accent
right now urban look at World War 2
there was a you're off topic right now
you're [ __ ] more I know that dude
you're [ __ ] off topic ok ok go back
this so how does that pertain to the
crocodile doesn't Wow
let's not make it Germans let's make it
any human enters into an environment
with the saltwater crocodile they're
coming right there merciless okay so
when we did so our crocodiles we worked
with an expert team like you have to
have special permits to get into places
where like you can get close to really
film them but these crocodiles are
completely wild but habituated to know
that okay if a boat's coming from you
guys are gonna get me to come up we
wanted to show the power of these things
you know you can see that picture there
that crocodile jumping out of the water
that may be in the same place that we
were filming so you've got these 17 foot
massive salties that can launch up out
of the water and we're dangling pieces
of chicken off the side to show you the
trap that they're literal and they don't
just kill you Brian they take you back
to their lair and sit with you in their
mouth for a day yeah your dead body is
sitting in a crocodile's mouth
you definitely mean look at the size of
that one
they're huge look at that you did not
get the water right no but I did ask the
questions if what would happen if like I
jumped off this boat into this mud how
quickly would one of these crocodiles
just go after me and the girl I was
working with it was like immediately
like you wouldn't even know what
happened there so fast there was one
there was a story I heard of a couple
sitting on a dock in Australia up in the
north and they were sitting there having
a beer and the guy turned heard a noise
look turn around and his girl was gone a
rock snagged her off the dock and her
family found her in his mouth I've heard
so many horror akka dolls did I get a
German guy in his heart I don't know
that might be Costa Rica No
that is not Costa Rica this is where we
filmed Beverly margarita saltwater crocs
are ask you a question yeah difference
between the Crocs there and the ones in
Kenya yeah well is there a difference
so saltwater crocodile vs. Nile
crocodile the two most dangerous non
venomous reptiles on the planet so now
Crocs just like Soltys will take down
anything that they have an opportunity
to grapple right so are the episode that
we have focused on saw water Crocs the
one that you guys know about because the
pictures like this but then there's also
something called the freshwater
crocodile which is the biggest little
scaredy-cat of a crocodile on the face
of the planet so it's the only true
crocodile of Australia because they're
only endemic to that continent and
freshies are actually really tough to
catch because you get within 20 feet of
them and they're like heck no I'm not
having anything to do with you
flashlight sounds so we ended up
catching a freshwater crocodile in a
completely different water system that
still had salty so it's dangerous to go
out at night into a river system trying
to catch freshies was impulsive salty
yeah in the water you were in the water
mm-hmm and there are salties in the area
coyote possibility of salties is
definitely prevalent but the waters not
as defenses it can't do that like an and
if a salty had presented itself you
better believe I would have tried to
catch it to get it I do you feel like
this is your parents fault for naming
you coyote he gives you an adventurous
life I got Bert I was gonna be a
comedian right he was Brian he had to
stand out he had to be funny yeah you
got coyote and you're like [ __ ] does
come from my mom nicknamed me coyote
after the Warner Brothers cartoon in the
roadrunner and you guys saw what
happened to the coyote all the time so
maybe it's just like well you're you're
due for self-destruction yeah but you
can't listen to me yeah I like you
you're a good guy and you're important
my kids worship you I can't have you
getting in the water where Soltys are
around right weren't you nervous it's
[ __ ] no because when I say getting in
the water there's also a lot of like
care and precision that's done to make
sure that okay if I'm going through this
body of water it's very unlikely that
I'm gonna run into a salty right so at
the deepest I was maybe like thigh deep
in water going after fresh what I've
seen is people can scuba dive with
salties mm-hmm
at a certain time of year when the
temperatures are cooler so when it's
real cold and they're underwater you
have to remember we also did another
episode on something called a shock add
a caiman which is another crocodilian
it's like a mix between a crocodile and
an alligator and I swam with them these
are 9 foot came in if you saw Shaka day
is spelled y AC AR e these caiman are
wicked looking creatures right I mean
this looks like something that would
willingly attack you not to hang I was
in the water surrounded by these things
and they don't touch you like they'll
come right up I mean I was inches from
open mouths
underwater to get these incredible shots
to dispel the idea that all crocodilians
are out there to eat you it's really
only it's really only Nile and saltwater
crocodile right and you know i mean
american alligators will grab their
locations - well I grew up in Florida
yeah they will they will the big thing
is that's their hunting strategy right
so the people that you've seen swimming
with with Nile crocodiles or saltwater
crocodiles are swimming with them at a
point when temperatures are at a certain
low point that they're not real active
and when you're underwater in scuba
equipment these reptiles lookie there
like you're not something I would be
eating it when you're on the shoreline
they're looking at a shape yeah and
they're like that's something I'm gonna
eat we're the size of the mammals that
they take down right so we're like a
two-legged deer and they don't
discriminate two legs versus four legs
that's a target I'm gonna take it but
underwater I'm not saying you're safe
and that anybody should just go do that
that's definitely not the case
that's how do you get killed in
Australia it's so much that when we were
tossed raelia and I don't know if you
had the board of tourism with you they
were like hey don't bring up how many
people would lose a year I don't talk
about the spiders the snakes they have
all the venomous minute snakes they have
all venomous spiders spiders they have
gray white sharks have crocodiles like
they're like please don't bring this up
it is fewer than you would think though
and it's fewer than you think total
number we could be out probably look at
under 14 I think it's it's definitely
fewer than a hundred people a year it's
it's less it might be I think it's less
than 50 people a year that are getting
killed a croc does this because
crocodiles animals animals go animals
under 14
oh are you saying animals in general or
crocodiles roll Crocs
I'll go cross I'm gonna say ten
but animals all together I mean there's
more people that get killed every year
by dogs than people that get killed by
cross-cutting allergies I know I'm
counting just like right wound
sustaining wounds me getting attacked by
dogs yeah but the thing is people have
become what's called crock wise right
like the Parks and Rec Department severy
buddy the wildlife societies in
Australia are doing a really great job
helping people recognize the signs no
that's not right no I would argue that
being a internet Wikipedia you can rely
on the world around the world that might
make sense in Africa okay those are
probably many that are estimated to be
unaccounted for there are a lot of
people that live in indigenous areas in
India they had this crazily inflated
number of people that were killed by
cobras mm-hmm and they were like this
makes no sense
ten thousand people doesn't make sense
you know people like you were like does
it make sense how and what they found
was that a lot of people when you brain
your wife in a domestic dispute they
would be like you got bit by a Cobra
yeah let's keep it quiet right a lot of
it was sort of they were part of rural
parts that were that were and and so and
if you killed somebody it would be like
the way you covered it up by it was by
saying he got bit by a cobra or throw
them into the crocodile pit but here's
the thing with Cobras because there's a
lot of snake charmers that have those
snakes in their houses yes that may be
more realistic but so the most venomous
snakes live in Australia but very few
people die from them because they've
done such a good job these different
venom milking programs we've worked with
that the top facilities in Australia to
milk not only the most deadly snakes but
also most deadly spider in the world
which is called the Sydney funnel-web
spider this thing is a literal living
nightmare and if you're bitten by one
you 100% will die if you're bitten by a
male spider if you do not receive
antenna is that right it is the only a
rat or the only spider that a hundred
percent will kill you if you don't
receive
look at antivenom damn that's cool yep
you can be you can be dead and again
remember I think we talked about this
before with venom it's all about how
your body reacts to the venom but geez
if you even if you're reacting you know
in a healthy sting you don't go into
anaphylactic shock like in less than 12
hours you're dead from this body
no thanks look at that thing those are
some sharp fangs so those those fangs
are longer than the things of any snake
in Australia so Australia doesn't have
this big holy yeah and the thing is
they're aggressive so you see what
they're doing there they have this
defensive pose where they rear up so
that those fangs can get into like
action pose and then they grapple on to
you and because they're curved but you
can't get them off it's not like you're
a little house spider they're like oh
you're brushing off your leg it latches
on you have to like rip it off of you
dude what the [ __ ]
crazy right time you have before you get
anti-venom I mean the great thing is so
the Australian Reptile Park that we
worked with they're producing like tons
and tons of venom by Milka so you see
there's venom coming off of the fangs
there so they milk that but it takes
thousands and thousands of milkings to
create this anti-venom serum but there
has not been a death from a Sydney
funnel-web spider and something like the
last 15 years or something like that
yeah it's making a huge scares the
[ __ ] there they're legit scary in the
episode that we did when I caught a male
so it's the male that's the most
dangerous so we caught one and we the
way we filmed the scene was we brought
it out into this flat area of ground and
I laid on the ground with it so we had
the camera super low which is engaging
for the audience this spider is inches
from my face if I'm presenting it's
nowhere I know what I'm doing I think
god damn let's get my lip or something
like I know dude wait hold on hold on
this is this is insane so we just out of
out of a production sense I've worked on
Travel Channel for like nine years
mm-hmm did you did they brought the
spider to you and you guys didn't go to
the wallet I know I found it in the wild
yeah that's the cool thing about brave
the wild is every single animal we do
not stage or source anything that's the
thing this may brave wilderness so pure
as a brand and a channels everything you
see I'm catching every one of these
animals and then
you always see them released back into
the wild yeah you won't you won't cheat
anything you go that's as I was that way
I was like don't make it where I like
I've got to act with a [ __ ] snake you
you can't the only scenarios that we
ever staged would be if we're working
with a Wildlife Sanctuary and we're
clearly saying to you we're working with
this conservation group today I'm being
put into this position but spiders any
sort of reptiles as often as possible
the mammals yes everything happens now
in India when the British had colonized
India they were having major problems
with Cobras Cobras were a real thing
mm-hmm and so the British decided we
gotta get rid of Cobras so they said
we'll pay they put out a thing we'll pay
you for we'll pay you you know five
dollars whatever it was for every Cobra
you catch and so people started coming
with dead Cobras you know and they would
get their money problem was that there
were there seemed to be more Cobras they
seemed to be more and more cobras and
what of course the Indians were doing
was breeding cobras because they can get
$5 from the [ __ ] British that's
[ __ ] so there is huge pits of Cobras
you just make it one industry out there
like we're not doing this anymore and
then they let all the Cobras free and it
was just a [ __ ] disaster
it's like that flood you hear about that
flood that flooded out the Crocodile
Park
oh yeah the Australian Reptile Park is
exactly where the place I'm talking
about we work there is huge so there's a
lot of problems happening with the
wildfires right now in Australia right
but in some areas there's actually an
insurmountable deluge of rain coming
down so along the coast where the
Australian Reptile Park is they had
massive flooding yep that's a year on it
right now and like they have this huge
alligator pit alligators obviously don't
exist naturally in Australia but they
have them there as part of the park and
the alligators were starting to like get
up and over out of what the enclosures
oh that's a big problem clearly holds
them back there are amazingly powerful
animals they are so the largest
alligator I've ever caught we did a
really cool series with Jurassic War
a couple years ago and we did this
awesome setup where we compared the
American alligator to Tyrannosaurus Rex
and we caught what we called a t-rex
sized alligator it was like a 650 pound
13 foot American alligator and it's just
crazy how they're like dinosaurs the
power is just unbelievable Jesus yes a
great show your new show basically you
go all over the world you've been in
India I've not not been to India yet no
but you you go all over the world and
you are doing what tell me tell us so
for season 1 a braid the while we filmed
in Australia South America Costa Rica in
the United States did you do the fence
team earns the a bit the guy from naked
afraid's foot and the guy was lost see
that's what I was trying to say oh yeah
I've caught plenty for Lance I actually
have a pretty crazy fare Lance story
that I'll tell to you quickly and then
I'll back into where we did sure I'm so
they're incredibly while camouflage
right it's arguably the most dangerous
snake in Central and South America
because they're very prevalent they're
very well camouflaged and people stumble
upon them they're aggressive in that
like they let you know if you get close
right they're like don't step on me I'm
gonna bite you but their venom is so
insanely potent that people will have a
hard time getting anti-venom so we're
filming in Costa Rica with a completely
different snake species that I found on
a tree and whenever you stop to film you
look around you to be like okay cool
there's nothing in the area there's this
palm leaf coming down there was hiding a
3-foot fare to Lance under it we did not
see it so I literally crouched down
inches from the snake and in the middle
of shooting this this scene with a
different snake that I'd taken off a
tree one of my behind-the-scenes guys
like coyote coyote fair lance and I
thought it was like a feral ants like
slithering out from the darkness toward
us so I just jump up quick naturally I
kid you not this snake is curled up
inches from me and the way I was
crouched if it had struck out admit me I
would have probably been bitten near my
kidneys tonight probably would have
killed me because there's no way to stop
that venom here bitten on your foot or
your arm at least there's a slower track
to hitting your vital organs so you get
bit on your kid
always [ __ ] wonder the venom venom
getting towards your bottom or always
great wonders this yes way worse way
worse so I was just fortunate the snake
didn't bite me there's footage of it and
when you're watching the scene before
it's called out you can see the feral
ants in the shot the entire time dude
yeah the number one reason people fall
out of trees because they're bad a
client bitten by feral Lance's no they
grabbed on to a snake thinking as a
branch number one reason people fall
don't ever get that like Germans Germans
how many Germans fall out a tree all
right man it seems like a lot I know
it's over a million they're like $1
these days they just fallen out your
Hudson right they live in trees so
correct your show I'm sorry yeah bad so
back to where we've traveled quite a few
locations this first season I mean all
my whole career is traveling to as many
places as possible but it's really about
getting into the brave the wild of the
purpose right because for television
it's bigger than just doing you know a
ten minute segment on YouTube we focus
in on what may be like the apex predator
of an environment and not something like
a lion or a tiger something that you've
never heard it before like a longfin
deal is an apex predator in that River
ecosystem but you never heard of it you
know I wouldn't think that I mean this
thing is an absolute nightmare for any
other animal that comes across so we
focus in on these animals you don't know
a lot about tell you their story how
they're surviving and if there's
something that people are afraid of or
some folklore or a misnomer we try to
dispel people's fears towards these
things so when I sit here and tell you
about crocodiles the whole purpose of
that episode is to say not all
crocodiles are out to get you if you put
yourself in range of a salty that's on
you how many times a year does a salty
eat as off as frequently they eat every
day if they can oh they well though
they'll gorge themselves the bigger and
fatter a big male salty can get the more
dominant he is oh yeah they'll just
every need yeah and they can digest
horns and everything everything bone all
of it it just like you know kind of
decomposes in their stomach and they'll
occasionally eat rocks that will kind of
bounce around inside there - he'll break
break that down and then they have a big
crocodile poop whatever that looks like
I've never seen a crocodile poop but
yeah geez and they're just great planet
they could feed us rocks and we could
probably help a lot of people that
acidity I saw a guy a guy a zoologist
told me he saw in Uganda a crocodile eat
a tyre because they'll eat anything they
made a [ __ ] tire he was like I mean
if it smells like it might be food yeah
cuz they don't discriminate
so what other what what what how many
episodes what places do you visit so
season one was a pretty big order for us
with animal plants so you gotta keep in
mind I went from YouTube to the first
time ever making a TV show what's cool
about this is this isn't coyote out a TV
show this is wilderness productions my
company producing the whole thing so we
got you a great idea because you're
gonna just a bunch of people to [ __ ] it
up if you don't yeah okay why you would
go from YouTube where you were sensation
and got so many people to see you yeah
Animal Planet because for me I'm a lot
of behind the scenes right I'm not just
a guy that pops in front of a camera to
tell you about animals I'm a producer
director and writer first and foremost
so I have the vision for what this show
is and when Animal Planet came to me you
know I love our relationship they're
fantastic I've been a huge Animal Planet
fan since I was a little kid growing up
on orwen and Corwin and all that and
when they came in and offered us the
show I said the only way I'm gonna segue
from YouTube because we still produce
YouTube while producing TV at the same
time is to say I have to have full
creative control I have to be the one
telling stories picking locations you
should targeting the animals and and
they were mean very much they get a
brain the Trump's you look yeah I mean
nobody knows nobody well if your your
thing is your enthusiasm and frankly
your childlike enthusiasm
I guess so old man you don't let him go
wait are you really 47 yeah I would not
have guessed that look I think as we get
old I had this conversation with
somebody yesterday we might be getting
older but I feel like everybody's like
staying younger because of the way
technology forces up they're like wait
you know when you're doing I think all
three of us are doing what we absolutely
love exactly I don't know what else I'd
be doing besides this and now it I was
walking in you know some I said on my TV
show I'm at Sony and it's 6:00 in the
morning I hate waking up early I'm
always late on the
but I'm walking there and I'm tired it's
my fourth day up at 5:30 and and I and I
looked at the beige walls that are Sony
I'm you should on these massive
soundless stages and and I and I just
had this overwhelming sense of gratitude
and I just went I'm doing what I always
dreamed of doing like I just felt so
lucky I was like it's 5:00 in the
morning whatever it is and I'm but this
is this is amazing it was cold and I was
in shorts and but I was just like you
know and I think when you when you are
engaged in on that level you do feel
young in fact if anything you're you're
become more conscientious about your
energy and trying to get more discipline
because it's what you want to do right
well you got to stay there you know
that's the big thing youyou've been like
I feel like Bert you you um have in the
past year or maybe you're and a half
have like blown the [ __ ] up with just
your own ability to do crazy social we
talked about on the podcast all time
your social media the you're such a
[ __ ] machine with the way you deal
with you well I I'm the I'm the opposite
of Coyote what happened for me was I was
a Travel Channel for nine yeah I was
doing stand-up looking for something to
happen did Animal Planet stuff did any
pilot they brought me this before the
internet got on Travel Channel and was
there for like nine years and I just
kind of I got bored one day I was like I
feel like I felt like a stripper I was
like I'm making good money I'm having a
blast but I'm not not really learning
anything and I'm watching my friends
just leapfrogged me and do like I
remember severa went to theaters and I
was like [ __ ]
so what I did is the opposite of what
you did I took what I learned to travel
channel about cameras and editing and
shots and and all that and I applied it
to my business and I thought we were
doing a weight loss challenge and I was
like oh I know how to slide music into a
cut make it sound edit out a part of the
song so I was shorter and it sounds
great
and I remember Rogen was the first one
that called me he's like dude you did
some visu Pahlavi do on a [ __ ]
treadmill I can't stop watching it what
song is that and I was like I told him
and then I started doing a vlogger it
started like doing it all that's how I
found you is I became really interested
in in in guys like you
were doing your own thing and I was here
I was from the system and so then what
happened was my only thing I ever cared
about was anyone seen me to stand up and
so then I just took all the [ __ ] that I
stole from guys like you Casey nice nap
Ben Brown fun for Louie all these really
great talented youtubers and I just
applied it to my business of going like
what would be fun what would be fun and
funny to Drai's to my Instagram to sell
tickets to a tour date mm-hmm and so I
just started doing that and it was
always fun like and by the way I'll tell
I'll say I stole from other greats like
like me and Tom started this battle and
I watched the way you and Julia and you
and sha would bust balls and Tom and I
were doing that now when this is I'm
interested in like the fact that Theo's
room was next door and I'm like I'm that
is interesting to me and so in a weird
way good job yesterday had a wrestling
match yeah I I got beat up by shop like
I've never been I've never if that would
be the equivalent of wrestling with a
bear yeah I was gonna say how did that
he's that strong well it didn't turn out
he could kill me with his bare hands
very quickly but what's funny is that so
many people loved it they loved that
ohev dude it's such an authentic like
and it's like so I'm doing the torch my
store starts January 30th in Burlington
Vermont two shows birdie boy world tour
but it's like all I did was I took I'm
going the opposite direction as you
right because I got I got I did what you
did on a smaller level I was doing
dangerous stuntman stuff and I started
resenting my crew cuz I felt like they
wanted me to get hurt might a show
called Herbert where I swam with great
white sharks out of a cage I was a
dominatrix camp I was a professional MMA
fighter for a day like I fought the
Gracie's I I did everything and I
started resenting my crew and I felt
like I was like if I die they're just
getting great footage so when you say my
crew so long if they stay on the shot I
was like yeah my crew did too I fell off
a [ __ ] waterfall and they just rolled
on me as I was like going guys I think I
broke my back and they're like and how
are you feeling right now yeah hey I
literally called my director and was
like hey man I feel like you weren't
there for me when I fell off a waterfall
he's like well I don't know what to film
and what not to film and I was like and
so that's what I wanted to ask you about
this show is like is there ever a point
where you go hey guys cameras
down I'm [ __ ] hurting like because
that's happened to me
I got concussed by the [ __ ] the XFL I
got choked out by the Gracie's I mean
I've had I had a I'm I felt like I've
had so much [ __ ] happen to me where I am
very distrustful of approaching right
all right here's the thing about rake on
earbuds they sent me a pair for free
because they put their money where their
mouth is and they wanted to see if I
would endorse them I don't I'm not gonna
tell you guys about anything that I
don't actually believe in that I haven't
actually tried and I had these in and
I'm actually listening to music while I
talk to you all right and you know what
they sound pretty darn good
they really do let's say I'm gonna play
another song this is gonna tell very
clear sound and they feel really good in
my ears see a problem with the other
ones made by a certain company that's
you know named after a fruit is that
they fall out of your ears these these
do not I can workout in them so I'm
already a fan and I'm listening as I'm
talking to you I'm listening to the
Indigo Girls Romeo and Juliet and it's
so clear I endorse these they're great
they're great and they feel good in my
ears okay well they start about half the
price of the other premium wireless
earbuds on the market all right oh my
god turn now and that's huge that that
really is huge because the earbuds that
you get from say other companies costs
between a hundred and sixty and two
hundred and seventy dollars these
average around I looked it up half that
so latest model the e25 is their best
one yet with six hours of play time six
hours so so it's got a great battery
life seamless bluetooth pairing I just
paired it in one second with my phone
more bass and a more compact design that
gives you a nice noise isolating fit
they're comfortable I just told you that
they were in my ears and they they feel
like something I could run in and spin
kick if I get in a street fight very
important for me because I like to fight
I don't like my music
in the way I don't like it to be
interrupted when I have to take a gang
out or I have to stop a crime so we're
talking about Wireless co-founded by Ray
J and I guess Snoop Doggy Dogg and cardi
B I don't really care about any of that
all right
I really don't I I just care that
they're good so I don't care what
celebrities behind these things and by
the way that means they're endorsing it
doesn't mean they developed it but
whoever developed them seems like a good
product so you can get the latest and
the greatest from Ray Khan 15% off your
order at by Ray con ro a Y Co n com /t
phat K that's by Ray Khan calm /t fat K
for 15% off rake on wireless earbuds
just as good as any earbuds I'm telling
you this because I just let's try them
and they seem pretty awesome they feel
heavy and they feel like they're good
quality so there it is
ray con earbuds they're putting their
money with him about this if you want
the best supplements on planet Earth
we say this all the time we just talked
about me and me and Bert Kreischer we're
talking about on it they've got this new
formulated alpha brain look if you're
dealing with focus if you want to deal
with better sleep better digestive
health better supporting vitality
whether it's creatine so many of their
products are not only taken by the
founders and the owners by me by people
that actually endorse this stuff I know
so many athletes that swear by it I
think that shroom tech sport I am
Telling You it's not a panacea I am
Telling You that stuff works if you want
a better workout try that troops room
tech support and email me or our DME and
tell me if I'm not right about that I
think I know it increases your your
endurance and I feel like my muscles I
don't know what it is dude because I the
reason I know it works is because I was
like I'm kicking better and my body felt
more pliable but I wasn't getting tired
after a long workout and I know for a
fact that stuff works so on and calm
slash fighter for the best supplements
on planet earth get it
right well okay so yeah to ant to answer
that to be clear my team that I work
with is a handpicked by me and a lot of
these guys are my boys that I've been
with since like college right so these
are people that got hired to come in and
help me make a show like what you do you
ever have a guy show up one day and he's
like hey let's let's [ __ ] this guy up no
they're good guys they're yeah no we
don't have right there's no influence
from anybody to ever direct me in a
direction like I'm Master and Commander
of the ship and and everybody knows that
I will let them know if if we ever need
to stop doing something and again you
have to keep in mind a lot of the risks
and the crazy stuff you see me do are
also very well calculated we do a lot of
research before I'm ever intentionally
bitten or stung by something and yes
something could go wrong in any instance
you could walk out your front door and
get hit by a garbage truck you know
was there one animal that scares this
[ __ ] Eddie um well when I got bitten by
that giant desert centipede which the
last time I was on here was saying you
were on the execution-wise from the
giant desert centipede and then I ended
up going through and you said the
executioner wasp was worse than the
tarantula hawk it was the execution wasp
but actually what's he also worse than
the tranche Hawk is the Japanese giant
Hornet which got a ton of attention
because people get killed by Japanese
jonno every year that was I was gonna
ask you about yeah dude that dumb nail
right there though that's you That's not
me the goat see the one with the finger
pointing at it down one down Oh God
with the low coyote head up one there
you go so that's the actual thumbnail
for the for the video that's you yes so
you're telling me that because they
sting your face your face melts or
something I heard my arm swelled up to
almost three times it's normal size when
its stinger went into my arm we caught
this on like slow-motion it was like
getting hit in the face by Mike Tyson
dude I saw stars and like toppled over
backwards what did that Hornet okay
sighs insanely powerful look at how big
and they attack you they'll attack
people ah they will if you disturb a
nest but they're not going to go out of
their way to grow and that guy has on
his hand
yeah now why is that my god somebody i
lo crazy I guess okay why after they
well they just sing over again well they
sting you if they're on your it's on
your hand so in an instance like that
because I don't know how this photograph
was taken or what the context of it is
uh one could walk on you not feel
threatened now if you were to apply
pressure to it its immediate instinct
it's like I don't want to get squished I
sting to help myself get away but
otherwise it'll it'll walk there pretty
harmless what they would they do is is
they're known as as B assassins so
Hornets will come in and just eradicate
honey bee nest know they'll kill 30,000
bees 30,000 bees is coming to decapitate
everybody they like there has a boom
just don't like their heads off one
after another after another so
beekeepers in Japan this is a real
threat for them like they try to that's
not realized obviously beekeepers in
Japan are constantly fighting against
Japanese giant Hornet since probably
beekeepers that end up getting stung by
them the most because they're you know
you try to kill a Hornet it's not gonna
be happy about that but we managed to
catch one and I did manage to get stung
by it and so that doesn't necessarily
scare me but it was the the giant desert
centipede that was a really tough one to
be bitten mom is there is like because
the venom is so potent the way the venom
works with a giant desert centipede so
if you search that I'll probably come up
right away so there's our thumbnail of
me putting it up to my finger and that's
also right on my arm
coyote what the coyote hold on I can't I
they're so horrifying to me they are
because all of their little legs have
hooks on them and you can't get them off
so this is a bite bites and stings very
different things right more venom comes
from a bite the way their venom works is
it literally attacks your blood cells
gets inside and explodes them from the
inside out so as this Venom's working
you yes you can feel the venom burning
and killing your cells on the inside of
your arm where did you do this on my
forearm and when you don't have any any
after effect I had I after effects for
about six weeks six weeks in this giant
like on like it's kind of like the size
of a like you know the size of a BB
times three so maybe like the size of a
marble a ball that formed in my arm
insanely itchy this was the only
incident where I actually had to seek
medical attention
hours into the bite the pain was so
intense my arm was so swollen I was like
a hot dog that was gonna pop I was like
I was afraid then what do they do what
do they do uh they give me very strong
adult advil aka good painkillers so we
is there is like I've had a scrub pepper
and you know that's what you did there
you just held your you're such and I had
to hold it to my arm it it bit me and
the thing was it was latched on and
after a bit it swung its head and bit me
a second time so I got bitten twice in
one like go at it is there is there a
point of meditative like in the pain
like I was saying I add a scotch bonnet
pepper in a certain point it's almost
like being in a freefall you start not
thinking about life yeah and you're just
gonna get me through this get me through
this like come on baby
come on here we go come on let's just go
and it's almost cleansing you know in
like a spiritual way do you find that
with the pain uh that's interesting you
bring that up I have a very high pain
tolerance
strangely enough and I don't say that to
be like oh I'm a tough guy I just I do
which is what makes this possible but
yes I do reach a meditative state when
the it's not usually in the pain that
happens initially it's you stub your toe
or yeah you cut yourself on a piece of
paper get a paper cut
eventually that pain goes away when it's
something like this and that pain
escalates over time escalates it
escalates so we're done filming the
scene and you wrap and you're like I
heard it got what it was Oh insanely
yes it's like insanely you can feel the
venom going ever seen oh yeah it's it's
it's no joke I mean in there there are
giant centipedes like in Vietnam and
stuff like that that venom powerful
enough to kill a human if you were were
to be bitten in the right spot and again
a lot of times it's how your body reacts
to the venom and in many instances I
mean just a bite in the pain can send a
person into cardiac arrest because your
heart your internal system doesn't know
how to deal with what you're going
through I hate centipedes they're
they're creepy I I won't say I hate you
reserve a purpose but they'd be an
uncomfortable fear into me and I think
I'm so squeamish about them that they're
horrifying they look horrified it is it
is it is a living alien nightmare and
the thing
again that's so scary about them it's
like imagine one of those crawling up
your pant leg every one of those little
legs you see has a hook on it so they
grapple on to you and then they bite and
chew it I mean why would they do it to
it they don't usually do here well they
don't unless you know you're out camping
in the desert and you're in a sleeping
bag that's on the ground and you don't
are you're not in a cot and one of those
goes in your sleeping bag and all of a
sudden you wake up and you're what's
happening to me and this thing is in
your sleep you're [ __ ] sleeping
backpack
well it wouldn't intentionally but if it
goes into your sleeping bag exploring
around for something to eat and then you
roll over on it it's thinking don't
squish me I'm gonna bite this is why I'm
not going I'm not camping in Vietnam in
the world's largest cave and the one
thing they said were bats and centipedes
yeah now this is that and then walking
in it was a six-hour walk into the
jungle where we up there in Vietnam I
treated the jungle and the one thing
they said were to stop grabbing on the
trees you will grab onto what you think
is a tree it'll be a pit viper yeah and
I was like it was the most unenjoyable
I saw eyelash Viper eyelash fibers on
Costa Rica or maybe it's a it's an
eyelash pipe yeah that little points on
top of this lucky long eyelashes it's
like two inches long right now yeah so
if you see it don't pull it but I have a
really long life that was a really hard
I don't know if that eyelash fibers are
honestly pretty docile though like I
mean beautiful yeah they're they're
amazing snakes they come in a bunch of
different you know I swear to god Kerry
I don't know about this but like I of
course evolution any sciences will tell
you that evolution is a very is it a
theory that is so provable it's
basically like a theory of gravity
mm-hmm however there's got any more to
the story it's got to be more to the
story than evolution this has to be some
kind of a simulation we're living it
let's look at that [ __ ] thing look at
how beautiful they are when I look at
certain animals they're so impossibly
beautiful that I I don't know I look
like a variety the variety of everything
in the world has to have another there's
got to be on maybe only the letter A
Hey look they are so Gortat left one
does look like a muppet right there that
looks like a muppet yeah well now you
know where we get our inspiration for
some of the weird creatures that are
created in cinema I mean a lot of
reptiles gave influenced Spielberg and
and the Stan Winston team that did
everything with Jurassic Park if you
search a geckos like tokay gecko for
example a lot of the velociraptor
designs and like their eyes and stuff
like that came from the eyes of geckos
because they're so just prehistoric
looking and while geckos are in no way
related to dinosaurs
you can still see though that that
similarity that exists in coastal winds
of reptiles when I was in college mm-hmm
like I read an iguana at a savannah
Monitor I had a Nile monitor for a
second than I TV backs was way too
aggressive nah monitors notice Nile
monitor Nile monitors laughing wait you
guys I've caught a Nile monitor five and
a half six foot Nile monitor
oh my caught in South Africa yeah big
big dangerous hell bites yet well and
this is one of the cool episode we did
this year on brave the wild I keep my
conversation more focused on the show
than other random stuff we caught the
largest monitor lizard in Australia
which is called a Parenti so if you
search the Parenti this is next to the
Komodo dragon this is Australia's
version of the Komodo dragon and man
they are just so cool this this thing is
when you look at your like this thing's
a velociraptor
for the most part it's a big lizards a
very smart would be great to have one of
those living in your backyard you you
could I mean some people do they're
they're very nomadic people will see
them in their backyards and they're not
afraid of humans like they'll stand
their ground and puff up their bodies
and look go ahead come close and see
what happens you know try to mess with
me they'll bite you they'll rip you
apart
really though if one of those gets ahold
of your arm you're going to the house
how big are they like that one right
there is probably about six and a half
seven feet holy Sh yeah and there is
their head is as big as this shoe right
here though they can eat a dog they
could they wouldn't but they do take
down mammals you the one with the the
back what they do Don it shows you how
big it is the German guy right there
you know I don't know if he's German
dude that's David Attenborough and I'm
gonna have to ask you to stop is that
David I'm pretty sure yeah I don't know
who is well he's the guy from Planet
Earth once there John pretty much the
Godfather of wildlife shows you guys
real pieces oh yeah all right let's not
top five top are wild list light wild
lipo swai live hosts of all time I Steve
Irwin number one Steve Irwin based on
what I think Steve built Steve's not my
favorite wildlife presenter though
outside of like what he did for
conservation in his career was the most
recognized right my biggest influence
action was a guy named Marty Stouffer
when I was growing up you guys remember
show called wild America I do so Marty
stop for Marty Stouffer yeah wild
America had the beard and those crazy
Christmas sweaters and him and his
brothers would go out and they were
filming all of these animals naturally
in the wild on like 16 millimeter film
like how they were getting the shots
they were getting I have no idea and he
didn't interact with the animals now
that was just a bad doesn't gate and put
Marty Stouffer in there and it'll come
up that's put but marty staffers great
also a guy named Austin Stephens if you
catch any his show Stephen Austin
Stephens in our production quality was
just next-level Wow look at that what
yours were those uh I mean I would say
these are late 80s early 90s
god I remember and he was probably
filming yours brother when you think
about how it takes like a decade to make
Planet Earth these guys are out there
making episodes I mean it's so hard to
see some of these things in the world I
can't believe how long it takes a planet
Earth like the amount of work that went
into it yeah if you ever see a mountain
lions in the wild oh yeah you have yeah
yeah I've had I've had mountain lion
experiences for sure really
yeah and Jaguars - we filmed we did we
had a crazy Jaguar encounter which you
don't realize how big a Jaguar is until
you are from me - that wall white
footage from a Jaguar on side of river I
was in a Jaguars den what tend the
Jaguars were literally 15 yards away
from me we didn't know it setting up
trail cameras and then we'd do this
episode that plays out there there -
that's in the new series this is the new
series we filmed this in Brazil
killing God the [ __ ] up I'm the humble
we got this epicenter a dangerous uh
aren't they I mean I would definitely
say that if a Jaguar had an opportunity
to take down a human it would probably
do yeah yeah there and they are way
bigger than you think
oh they're three hundred my dad says ran
a pen and a very reliable either who
works with big cats yeah he said Tigers
because they're solitary animals they're
not at they so some Tigers you can't go
in a cage with it did they have
personalities some Tigers are are
actually pretty docile and you can tame
they can they can be tamed don't fall
down
do not fall down or turn it back to a
tiger that kind of stuff or pull it by
its tail or pull buds tail or punch in
the face he'll Lions more dangerous
because they're social animals and they
have a pride so they they they they
communicate mmm
Jaguars he said forget it don't try to
tame a Jaguar well you don't realize
about Jaguars is like so Lions hunt with
you no pride mentality right their goal
is to take down their prey by using
strategy but a Jaguar hunts using
stealth so that Jaguar is going to be
there watching you and it's gonna make
it's moving you'd never even know it now
not and I feel like I was in danger when
we were filming Jaguars no but if you
want to have a crazy adrenaline rush put
yourself in the middle of nowhere with
Jaguars
and realize that yes they're here and
we're just trying to get them on cam how
did you so we're gonna see this on your
show right
that's the little teaser on on why you
weren't nervous well we were when we
were there so the the Shaka day came in
that I was telling you about that we
were swimming with we were there to film
with these caiman and there were also
Jaguars in the area because the Jaguars
hunt the caiman so the Jaguars move
along the shorelines and so those famous
shots that you've seen of Jaguars
jumping in like grabbing these
crocodiles and pulling them up onto
Shore where I was is exactly where these
things are happening right so for me to
be in the water swimming with the came
in with those cuddling in a camouflage
hex aquatic suit I look just like a
caiman so there's this danger of
swimming by we came in I'm gonna eat
this came and it's not swimming as good
as the other caiman I yeah yeah a bad
idea but
you know that the Amazon doesn't have
any crocodiles you have to be worried
about right so we filmed this in we
filmed in an area called the Pantanal
right which is like the southeastern
part of Brazil and no there's no
crocodiles it's just came and the
largest came in species that species
they have is what's called a black
caiman and those are aggressive they're
dangerous I mean if you go out swimming
at night in the water like yeah you'll
probably get eaten by one oh really
yeah by a black caiman yeah black caiman
would definitely eat a human event is
that true how big are they things left
about twelve feet in length oh [ __ ] I
didn't of all the caiman species the
black caiman is definitely the most
dangerous most of them are pretty
skittish and docile the black caiman are
up there from you don't want to be in
the water with black camp no mm-hmm oh
no and they do these people I'm not
saying that they do mean people I'm
saying if you were a human in their
environment at the time where they're
hunting there's a good chance it would
try to eat and they're big animals they
are and they have killed people so it's
fair to say okay I'm trying to phrase it
to say they don't go out of their way to
eat people but if you're a person and
you're dumb enough to go into the
environment at the time where an animal
like this would be hunting but yes they
can grow some about 12 feet they max out
at and you can tip the scales around 350
to 400 pounds yeah it is but and that
doesn't sound that heavy except for the
fact that and no that's not right they
don't grow up to 20 feet long this is a
bad internet animal corner whatever that
is is not accurate so yeah you know it's
what's the power that's the most
dangerous power the power in these
animals that's so dangerous once they
grapple onto something they have in
their mind that like oh this is prey
you're not getting away the power isn't
overwhelming I fought a bear one time I
don't know that's true Burt when was
this I need to get a bear okay nice hear
you're done 2002 you don't know the
exact date no I was were a TV show well
what kind of bear was it just up to five
up to five I got okay you say so I tried
tamed lions that day hold on what kind
of bear was part of grizzly big [ __ ]
there are layers named
bamboos okay see a department
I'm the bear I'm the bear he's like
Godzilla five so you fought you fought a
video bear the [ __ ] woods
you didn't go revenant DiCaprio against
Lee I really did do this I really did no
I'm being serious but you wrestled a
bear so they it was a it's a bear that
was in like it's a movie bear and so
they were like yeah we can wrestle him
so I go up for the show I had heard Burt
and they're like all right here we go
they're paper I'm a grizzly bear there
you go
so and they go all right he's gonna I
think I wrestled BAM Bam's mom if I'm
not mistaken and so they put his on her
arms on your on your shoulders she
grabbed onto my ears and the second I
felt her just a smidge of her power
I went oh I'm helpless like I you didn't
you don't realize you always think
you've got some kind of shot in your
head in the wild you're like bear shows
up my kids I stand in front of my kids
I'd go for the Bears like you think of
some dude or food you've heard about she
mean I can't believe they let you was
you was she muzzled no they just let you
wrestle with a jack wrestled a [ __ ]
bear I would never do that
I tamed lions that same day and man the
the subtlest the when you see that
instinct click over and you watch them
go like like when I went went to fight
lions they were like they're like how do
you tame lions and they go oh here take
this fanny pack full of sirloin and this
plunger stick with a nail in it and
they're like that's your meat stick
don't drop it
put meat on the tip of the meat stick
they'll they'll pay attention why the
plunger part that's it's not-it's just
upon your stick oh I pictured like a
plunger with a nail coming out think
about the thing about animals when you
are around the wild animal I think it's
an old stain because for human beings is
something about we're very self-centered
as people even if you're a giving person
you think of yourself as a human you
think of yourself as the top of the food
chain one way or another when you are
with an animal I pet a cheetah one time
and any kind of them like that you
realize that they don't care about you
that they that you are so insignificant
to them that you are either being
completely ignored or if they want they
can turn you into food it's very
humbling mm-hmm you know it's kind of
all on spot great white sharks man they
move with such in such a
just intention I was in the out of the
water out of the cage with great white
sharks just off Catalina mm-hmm
and four same show Herbert and the great
white sharks showed up we were blues
yeah great white sharks showed up you
always think you know how you start
racing that huh oh I jumped out of the
water immediately but it moved so
quickly with intention like when it
wanted to go left it went left so quick
yeah it's fun it's really amazing I have
not I've not filmed great whites yet I
have with tiger sharks and hammerheads
and was almost bit in the face by a
14-foot tiger shark like just missed
being in the jaws of a tiger shark and
not to fault of the tiger shark so if
you search coyote Peterson tiger shark
abandom image will probably come up good
call on the part of words you should
look v the shark they have feeding
responses right so they sense with their
noses and so face off yes
match that one the far right there that
that's that's me that's how close that
this shark came full mouth open and I
dodged out of the way but it's because I
was filling with the GoPro and with
these tiger sharks we were working with
the team were working with they're like
yeah just let the shark swim into it'll
bounce off but don't push the nose up
I accidentally triggered a feeding
response and his whole mouth came open
to my face was looking right down his
throat and it wasn't aggressive by any
means but if he had grabbed my arm
thinking it was something tall he's not
the thing that's dangerous is is she's
going to shake a little bit realize this
isn't what I want but he's gonna open me
up to a state when you're that far out
in the middle of nowhere like your odds
are bleeding out most people in shark
attacks died because they bleed out not
because the shark is ready he could also
take your arm off pretty easily with
with like like well like we bite meat
off a chicken it's true if you had to
pick one animal to eat you and that's
your way out everyone go run things what
animal to eat you and that's your way
out no no no animal although let's go
dinosaur so these would be a lot quicker
yeah man that's that's tough I'd only go
out by a whale accidentally swallowing
you know that's not what you want
process I would probably say shark
because the thing is like a bear a bear
will take its time because in most
instances like your legs bears bears
don't really eat humans especially
Grizzlies Grizzlies want to eliminate a
threat and your best plan of attack in a
bear attack if it's a grizzly is to try
to play dead right so the revenue with
Leonardo DiCaprio where he was like
trying to just like take the beating
that is the best thing you can do
because all that bear is doing is
wanting to eliminate the threat from its
territory but like a black bear Black
Bears will eat humans more people are
eaten by black bears that are predatory
that's why you have to fight back you
gotta fight a black bear if it's
attacking you're not gonna do the play
dead thing but with a grizzly if you can
endure through you want to protect your
head and your neck because that Bears
gonna try to break your neck in and stop
like just put you out right funny I'm
thinking about this story wise like how
do I want my story told after I'm gone
yeah I got a bear everyone's like me it
would be a big cat big cat long is it
because a Jaguar or a lion grabs you by
your [ __ ] neck yeah but it's gonna
break your neck quick gonna break your
neck yeah wait wait tell the story tell
the story is if third party okay you're
not Bryan Callen yeah but I'm a guy the
bar and I'm talking about Bryan Callen
and you tell me how he died okay yeah so
this is the part that matters to me okay
yeah I mean I did I love the Goldbergs
Bryan columns like my favorite actor
dude I used to love fighting the kid his
stand-up whatever happened to Bryan
Callen friend of mine oh you knew Bryan
died yeah I was privy to the video into
the to the auditorium wow we went out
you saw the video I saw the video well
boy how did he die
well they were in India and he was
helping the local populace there and he
was very much into women's rights and
just human rights I don't know that but
it's a real champion of the people and
he gave and gave and gave and they were
they were out digging a well for this
wonderful village and he did it by hand
I don't know if you ever saw his back
the road man he sounds like he was
really strong he could do yeah it could
take a while on an afternoon
I don't know anybody like that I was an
actor but he was a really out quite an
athlete and love really moved him oh
yeah yeah I was a fan of his too how did
he die there was he was with a group of
women there was this charity where they
had all of the Miss America runner ups
with him and some of the girls
especially who had been exposed for
doing some nefarious nude stuff that
missed America didn't want anyway he was
there and he was keeps a natural leader
and he had taken them on a fact-finding
mission yeah they were they were helping
him and providing inspiration for the
world digging and stuff and but how did
he die so he was he used to dig in a
loincloth and he yeah and he that was
fashioned for him by one of the one of
the local and very beautiful young
ladies and he a tiger Shere Khan sure
Collier come
that's a Hindu for tiger showed up and
came out a woman and I know Brian
mustard he did not like when wild
animals [ __ ] with women he didn't like
when a he didn't like with directors are
free he was at shanty anyone wild it'll
be enough women's rights and human
rights I don't know if I said that
before that guy gave till it hurts and
he said not on my watch [ __ ] and he doe
did give mostly fast-twitch muscles so
it was amazing how fast he dope and it
was funny to see in midair because they
slowed the camera down the line the
tiger
recognized in midair you could see his
expression change it recognized it was
gonna have its hands full and recognized
that this dude when he pulled his knife
from his loin cloth and he went not on
my watch [ __ ] and he he jumped sort of
into the maw of the tiger and he drove
his knife and he didn't want to hurt the
tiger and this great [ __ ] guys
beautiful about him you could see him he
was about to plunge the knife and he
went No and he dropped the knife he put
the tiger into his guard and he brought
the tiger in and he said I love you to
the girl and to the tiger and the tiger
got him by the neck and he died smiling
if and the tiger
surprisingly let go of him and walked
back into the bush and this is so
[ __ ] crazy but it bowed to him I
bailed
yeah it's this is weird Carrie you would
know this but it put its pause and it
just kind of put its nose to the ground
and went and it screamed and I hollered
and I heard this story I heard that that
some say and this is folklore yeah that
Brian became that time
it's so [ __ ] weird cuz it couldn't
find his body that was it a tiger
loincloth it was he was wearing a tiger
one with someone please please make that
artwork of Brian flying through the air
grabbing a tiger who's flying in the air
with one under one under armed with a
knife kind of dropping it but the Tigers
recognizing it please please please I
will pay to make those shirts and I will
give them away I give away a hundred
shirts if someone writes that I'm known
in India's and degree and I think you
need to just transcribe all that and
there's your next pitch for Netflix
right there he did this is it just came
out with a great story
that's a horse out over there with this
no Bert was strangled by an anaconda in
a zoo watched him breathe by a funnel
spider and and died screaming with a
very small in arm dude I got stung by a
bee the other day and it hurts my fly's
down
it's so bad and it's I was at a bee
thing and we were we were beekeeping and
someone was like see because there's all
over the place you like see if it would
sting you so I lifted my shirt up and I
was like see if one lands and then it
landed and I panicked so I put my shirt
down and I covered the bee in my shirt
that's the worst thing he could have
done
no [ __ ] coyote I then started punching
the bee and it just stung me and it
swelled up huge yeah what about African
bees well that's a great one
for me to tell you guys that we for this
season no baby episode 13 thousand bees
in a beard if you won't it won't come up
on and I'll bring it up on my phone real
quick to show you guys the picture so I
wore 13 thousand bees I think you guys
know baby look what happened after I was
on the show last I got stung 60 times in
the face by bees so if you search you're
gone wrong search be beard gone wrong
what else see what why did that happen
to you because Africanized bees got in a
fight with European honey bees on my
face and go to images go to go to
anymore come up so there there you go
now that's what happened to my face is
that true yes I 60 times by bees yeah
look at his lip you live like this Pius
I look like a swollen hotdog but we went
back to Arizona and I said incredible
hold on they were Africanized so the
African bees stung the [ __ ] at look at
that yeah yeah I got my lips my neck my
around my eyes so this was I was trying
to wear a beard with about 2000
Photoshop that's your remote that's real
so for the show we just did another bee
episode I did 13 thousand bees how heavy
is your face here that's about 11 pounds
worth of bees what do they put like a
queen bee in your mouth so I wore
something called the Queen's necklace
which is a queen bee inside of a little
capsule and all of the other worker bees
that were in this hive they just want to
come to the Queen so they basically
covered me now what happened and the one
that went wrong how do you get them off
you used my the experts scoops them off
with his hand I was stung four times
filming this scene so way less than
sickening bill stung still stung four
times process cuz the bees were like no
don't take me away from the Queen so
some of them would sting when they're
getting taken away that's a big problem
dude yeah now but that episode is crazy
awesome intense can I tell you where you
take it to the next level dude beer B
pubes
it makes your dick bear
no look at this [ __ ] cage dancing did
you know that they were Africanized no
so what happened with this is where we
were filming so Africanized bees are
like a big sort of thing that swept the
nation in like the early nineties with
this idea that there's killer bees
killer bees are what are called
Africanized bees right and they're only
killer bees in that people have died
from being stung by them right they're
not going on their way to necessarily
kill people but we're more attractive
yes they are more aggressive and when
they are from Africa indigenous to
Africa originally it it it originated
there and through people doing bee
keeping there were some tests that were
being done and it's a much longer story
but yes eventually Africanized bees had
escaped interbred with calmer European
honeybees and because there was just
listening to it it's all more more
intelligent European bees just interrupt
you for a second Jared Diamond and con's
Germans and steal one of the one of the
ideas was that one of the reasons Africa
did not develop as quickly as say the
Fertile Crescent Babylon and what's now
at Rock the Middle East Europe was
because you couldn't domesticate in
sub-saharan Africa
you couldn't domesticate any of the
animals and it's a real thing you can't
raise cattle you cannot raise goats you
can't raise any other stuff when you
have large cats when you have smaller
cats they will decimate I love hearing
chewiness you can't tame an elephant you
can't domesticate an elephant you can't
domesticate the water buffalo they will
kill you
you can't ride a zebra they will bite
and not let go so all of the animals in
Africa and are simply not you can't
domesticate you can domesticate cows and
oxen and horse and all those animals
that were indigenous to that area and oh
by the way edible grass is like barley
millet arimin --then and wheat grew
naturally in places like 'wow iraq and
those places so you you could you could
and and you also couldn't really plant
in an area that got rain that often in a
jungle there were just too many issues
too many insects that would eat your
crops so you had to be a hunter-gatherer
you had
to hunt and when you are that way when
you in small bands of people are the
only way you can survive because you can
have feed enough people mm-hmm so you
you so you couldn't organize into law so
you of course you became very tribal and
small when you have an ability to create
agriculture and and and cereals and high
energy foods that allow you then to have
a lot of people in one area and that's
when you have government organized
armies organized technology the sharing
of ideas the sharing of information that
was not the case in in Africa and oh by
the way the diseases were I mean yellow
fever and all the it got to a point
where the slave traders European slave
traders had to rely on other Africans to
give them their slaves they couldn't go
into the interior because they always
always got sick and died Wow I love
hearing [ __ ] like interest me people ask
me what to read all the time read Guns
Germs and Steel by Jared Diamond it's it
won a Pulitzer Prize it's an amazing
book Guns Germs of steel I'm getting all
audiobooks right [ __ ] great book keep
going so the bees yeah Africanized bees
are more aggressive but for again that's
I mean it's a great example because
they're dealing with predators like
honey badgers right so when an
Africanized colony is attacked by
predator
unlike European honey bees they send out
somewhere between sixty and eighty
percent of their hive to attack the
attacker whoa in my instance what
happened is we were using calm docile
European honey bees to build that first
bee beard the location we were in some
Africanized bees had gotten mixed in and
in the flurry of what was happening the
second I got stung the first time my
first sting came on the lip when a bee
stings it sets off a pheromone that
tells the other bees we need to attack
something my face just sort of
inadvertently became the punching bag
for these bees getting in serious
trouble well a single bee sting can kill
a human depending how your body reacts
with venom if you go into anaphylactic
shock so to be stung as many times as I
huh about 60 times on my face arm XenApp
hands legs yeah that's so much pain
mm-hmm it was in terrible
one of the most intense pains I've ever
gone through here when your face is
going through that transformation
swelling it felt like my lips were gonna
explode they were like overly cooked hot
dogs it was crazy I was I was scared
like your heart rate starts going so
fast cuz you're like holy cow this is
insanely painful I can't stop it and
there's a lot of venom inside you take
do you take anti-venom no not for this I
mean after 20 minutes when you're like
okay you haven't gone into anaphylactic
shock you're like you're gonna be okay
are you are you do you are you able to
build a resistance to venom the more you
get stung the more your body's used to
it or they're really obviously well some
people become more susceptible to them
so me wearing the beard the second time
we were actually worried about is that
my body built up an over sensitivity to
the venom where a single sting could
shoot me into anaphylactic shock because
you have to think when I got stung that
many times my body went into like
massive overdrive this is like you know
a Dodge Viper on nitrous like is fasiq
you got my body's like holy cow dude you
just got stung 60 times by bees where
you want hard for your money I mean this
wasn't even supposed to happen so when
it went at Daniel we didn't go into the
bee beer being like sweet dude you're
gonna get stung a bunch the guy was
working with us like know you might get
stung once or twice so he felt really
bad and when we came back to do another
bee beard free animal plant he's like
you sure you want to do this again I'm
like yeah let's go for it made you
famous so when you know when you this is
you don't have to answer this when you
know you're making good revenue on
YouTube correct you go into Animal
Planet you come in with a price that I'm
certain they're like oh no no no we only
give that to stars like we only give
that to Jeff Irwin or Kirwan or whatever
his name is and you go no no no this is
the show I do and this would already
make it must be like talking to like old
people um without divulging too much of
the like financials of what it is I
found myself in a very unique position
because of the brand we had built yeah
more famous than any of those good me or
more famous than the network well the
brain whale and his channel has been
viewed 3.1 billion times at this point
in the course of five years we've got
fifteen point five million it goes 3.1
billion views is what we have generated
on the breakwall there's a lot of people
watching all around the like watching
burn kids have watched everything I
wanted
you should I'm in today well here's
what's cool about YouTube is is YouTube
is constantly ticking right like with
television it's an awesome world to be a
part of but you're at the mercy of air
box right with YouTube there are people
watching the brave wilderness Channel
every second of every minute of every
hour of every day of every week of every
month of every year until we turn it off
it just constantly goes and goes which
is the best way the biggest microphone
you can have for reaching people
especially like your kids I mean you
guys thank you for appreciating what I
do you know as big kids you're like dang
this is crazy this is cool and young
kids are like dang this is crazy
well as your is I want to learn about it
your enthusiasm your personality all
that stuff I mean this is a this is a
look Congrats dude you've in in the
insane noise in the cult of amateur
world that the Internet is in the big
sketch that it is and all you have
figured out a way to capture people's
imagination and attention and you've
done it in a really positive way because
kids learn a lot man my kids like like
they when I showed them that video I was
so cool my daughter I am not to be a you
know when I'm with my daughter or my pin
my son in the air probably get rekt you
know you get recognized and all that and
they could give a [ __ ] about that when I
showed them I knew you and I had a video
they they literally lost their [ __ ]
mind
forgot about that my daughter's my
daughter showed me your video came into
my mancave yeah I was like that you
gotta see this and I was like what is it
she goes dad type in coyote Peterson and
I was like typed it in and at the first
video I'm like I'm like I said this
before you walked in I am really good at
telling you cool [ __ ] I found hot ones
way before everyone was in love with
that I found that reached out to Sean
Evans was like dude whatever this is I
want to I want to link up with you you
were got it Ethan Ethan and Eli Klein
h3h3
I found those guys so long ago I was
like bro get like [ __ ] UI whatever
you do I want to be a part of when I
watched you I just I can just telling
shits good
I [ __ ] was I was like oh I let pull up
your chair we're gonna be watching all
of these man I appreciate that what is
your show I'll be showing Netflix where
I take I take celebrities to a cabin and
there's not celebrities it's comedians
we go to a cabron and basically try to
ruin our careers technically that's what
the show really is yeah a lot of editing
around this but but we just do cool [ __ ]
and try to like do stuff to like clear
your mind body and soul it's kind of
like a I don't know man i I'm afraid to
talk too much about it because we've
done we've done some stuff where you're
like like I'm Bobby Lee was on it I
should explain enough it was [ __ ]
awesome we were there for a month in a
cabin in the woods and it was it was so
much fun that I'm like like I just hope
everyone likes it yeah it sounds like a
good setup for horror film to like
comedians and cabins getting like hills
Rangers well I was naked a lot a lot of
it so you were that character there was
a lot of dude every man a man cry every
rule that people get upset about in
comedy yeah well inadvertently we
stepped on every [ __ ] rule not even
trying it was never our intention
it was just I get so much love for that
for that crab episode where dude people
loved it that you and that was my
favorite that was when we didn't know
what something's burning was we've done
like one episode and you a shop came in
and when you guys did that episode I
went oh now I know what the show is a
lot of what a lot of what making a
television show we're making any content
these days I won't say that something's
burning is a television show but it's
the internet project a lot of it is just
finding out what it is for you that's
what everyone how did you start that
like with YouTube um well because I I
pitched the concept of brave wilderness
for a number of years to different
networks and everybody just told me no
there's like there's I think when Steve
passed away everybody got really afraid
to put a human with animals right so I'm
talking about Steve Irwin and everybody
said no and at that time the shows like
duck dynasty and like these ensemble
casts were a big thing and they were
like the turtle [ __ ] guy the turtle
guy there was there was nobody
they were like nobody wants to see a guy
presenting animals we had planet Earth
and they're like that's how animals
should be seen and planet Earth is
fantastic don't get me wrong I'm not
otherwise Dominic from the guy up from
from The Hobbit
yeah Dominic Monaghan he had a show on
Travel Channel get wild things yeah and
it was love Dominic he's a great actor
he's a great talent
yeah who's such horseshit they brought
the animals in for him and you knew it
they're like all right should be an
alligator and they'd walk over an
alligator I'm like bro don't eat it do
it or don't do it yeah you know well I
don't know how he produced his show so
I'm not saying he did or didn't do
anything I you know when it comes to
environment stealing he went into I know
he did a lot of really legit see loved
animals that worried about it I think
it's awesome that he had a passion for
what that was and and bounced from Lord
of the Rings to lost to like a nominee
an animal show would you ever do any
hunting that's not your thing um I I
don't hunt I'm not one of those people
that's like people shouldn't hunt I
don't support any like predator hunting
people are like yeah I'm gonna go out
get a trophy lion I'm like why but for
people that hunt deer and elk and stayin
I like the eggs I'd like to eat it we
have an overabundance of deer I've never
understood like I just could never kill
a bear rhinos okay but like something
right I was shooting because I don't
know why no elephant even rocks I
totally get it
lay down next yeah lion with a
high-powered rifle
I mean look even you even you're in your
narrative like you you couldn't kill the
tiger you gave your life to the time in
your death I mean I I really don't
understand how anybody could kill an
animal when you really think of it we as
humans have impeded upon everything that
they were before we got here so if you
find yourself in a scenario like look if
it was me versus me and my daughter and
a mountain lion I'm not gonna be like
all the mountain lines beautiful I'm
gonna let you eat my daughter obviously
I would would fight in that situation
but I would do everything I could to
like back an animal off before ever
thinking about like all right I'm
working I'm going I'm going violet you
had some experience in the mountain line
there very long the more experience with
bears honestly I have been in the same
scenario they portrayed in the revenant
you guys have seen the brothers ride
with Leonardo DiCaprio yeah I was in
exact words with that movie exact same
scenario a mother bear three cubs side
of a
her middle of nowhere Alaska a hundred
yards and closing and she couldn't hear
us or smell us because we were downwind
and the water was so noisy she didn't
know we were there and we eventually got
her attention and I'll tell you what
there's nothing that makes your heart
drop faster than a giant mother grizzly
bear standing up on her back legs within
like 75 yards and then looking at you
and saying I'm either going to kill you
guys because these are my Cubs or I'm
gonna get my Cubs and go in the opposite
direction and thank God she dropped to
the ground took the Cubs and when the
opposite direction but that's one of
those scenarios were like a bear can
cover 75 yards in seconds did you have
guns no with his family in the woods
bear downwind river behind him sees him
he pushes his wife's down bear grabs his
Cubs and walks away and I'm like oh
sorry baby sorry oops you dropped
something yeah I I would never go into
bear territory without without a weapon
well you know here's the thing about the
weapons do they tell you to carry an air
horn or bear spray right like here's the
thing about a grizzly if you fire up a
mother bear and she has it in her head
that like you're a threat to my Cubs I'm
about to take you out I mean you're
gonna have to be so lucky to hit her
with like a shot to like take her down
her Adrenaline's going so fast you're
still gonna get attacked that's the same
thing with bear spray - what I didn't
know about bear spray because after this
incident happened like we were like well
we got to know what this bear spray does
I thought it was like Hornet spray that
would spray like 25 yards and I could
like aim at it the Bears eyes - dude it
comes out in a plume and all it does is
creates this cloud so the Bears coming
at you it's gonna run through it and
it's gonna get in its eyes and its nose
it's so gonna attack you but you have to
hope that it's like disoriented enough
that like maybe you can get away in the
process yeah like if a bear is gonna
attack you like your odds of getting
away are not very good I always go with
SEAL Team six and they're armed to the
hilt that if you have the opportunity of
SEAL Team six with you on the
backcountry of Alaska I would think
that's probably better than bears but
after you do mm-hmm well I'm excited
about your show wild it's called brave
the wild brave the
yeah Premier's some congratulation thank
you and I say that because what I'm
congratulating is a guy who had a dream
that no one understood that did it on
its own and now they've had to turn and
come to you that is what is the future
of this businesses and to see guys like
you succeeding gives me hope and I feel
like I've done some stuff but man I go
yeah you can always make your own [ __ ]
and they'll have to come to you also
what you do is so pure you know thank
you
oh it's cool to us we're producing this
out of Columbus Ohio you know what I
mean most people are like wait there's
no there's no entertainment industry in
Ohio Columbus are you I'll be doing
stand-up there I can't remember when
oh well definitely let me know I March
February 2nd I'll be in Dayton in the
birdie boy world by the way I'm in
Cleveland this next weekend I think
we're almost sold out I think we're sold
out I think they're tickets left for
Thursday January 30th and then we got
January 31st and Saturday the first they
wanted to add three an extra show on
Saturday I was like not doing that Oh
can't do three shows up in the back I
can't do it I can't anyway so so get
your tickets and then now West Palm
Beach February 14 15 16 I'm there for
Valentine's Day Kate York tickets see
fat K comm coyote what else can we Bert
where are you gonna be oh I'm gonna be
in pretty boy World Tour starts January
30th apparently tomorrow Vermont
Rochester Dayton San Jose Sacramento
Bakerfield Indianapolis two shows in New
York City at the what's the name of that
theater Lincoln or not Lincoln is it the
Madison Square Garden beacon beacon
beacon beacon that's a big deal
so tube you sold out the beacon twice
yeah that's no joke thank you well done
Bob thank you so much you that's the
beacon is a great I can't wait I'm
really excited DC we're doing dark
constitutional two shows tampa two shows
wow yeah we just added a bunch of second
show many people this constitutional Oh
25 I'm guessing 25 only 25 yeah just
about it borrows some money okay I'm
working late so when does the show air
give us all these so what's cool is is
we're doing a sneak peek on Superbowl
Sunday
so Puppy Bowl is a huge thing for Animal
Planet so puppy bowls like their big day
of the year right so there'll be a sneak
peek right after Puppy Bowl so five
o'clock Eastern Time on Feb
second but the show really premieres
February 9th Sunday February 9th at 9
o'clock
tune in and yeah this is I'm confident
saying this is where it's placed in time
the greatest animal adventure series
it's been produced ask me where I'm
gonna be a Super Bowl Sunday where are
you gonna be on Super Bowl semester
Stallone's house oh wait no you're gonna
say a date I was putting on my Instagram
you're gonna be a semester splits well
I'll be but I mean on this weekend I'll
be a Cleveland at hilarities hours to
February and then West Palm Beach
Valentine's Day make sure you post it I
got it this is great I do a cabin it's
called cabin yeah do we we and you're
naked in the picture I mean I can't tell
too much about the series but like all
I'll tell you is one of my [ __ ]
hardest I've ever laughed ever is we
were doing scream therapy me Bobby Lee
and Donna Rollins and we were trying to
we're trying to talk to our fathers and
tell us things that was going on with
their fathers just past so I go Bobby
yell to your father and he's like I have
a hard time doing it and then Don I was
like I'll just be your father and he's
like Oh Bobby son and so oh my god I
know you can't do that is racist and
then Bobby goes I'll be your dead please
leave any I do so money get out so much
black and then a Korean guy it was that
racist every episode I was crying
laughing I was getting healed by more of
that we need more of that
cross-pollination and using humor to
break down all that horseshit and worst
case scenario you're gonna have like
this whole stack of like b-sides that
are like the cabin journals that as you
know internet-based content as me what
I'm doing at 7:35 speed I'm doing a 7
o'clock we're doing 7 I have a wrap
party for the cabin that's right you
told me that ask me what I'm doing at 7
o'clock on at 7:00 I'm just having
dinner with my sister and her husband I
don't know they're taking me someplace
for for sushi her her husband's a pretty
awesome writer yeah I leave tomorrow
morning
Stephen corn he Seinfeld
yes team corn tell you some ID click
wait wait hold on hey can I tell you the
[ __ ] craziest round-robin circle of
this do you know who one of the writers
on my world's dancing Dog Show was
Stephen Korn swear to you on my [ __ ]
children really we swear to you on my
[ __ ] children I will ask him to use
he we did I tell you about the dancing
dog show yeah Stephen corn was my
[ __ ] he came out to Solvang
he was good friends with one of the John
Hotchkiss was one of the red writers and
who created the show and Stephen corn
was one of the [ __ ] writers and I was
like oh that's so [ __ ] what a great
writer dude he's got an amazing great
he's a funny guy nice is not a show to
say before yeah sisters married to
Carrie Peterson
they always welcome Thank You Peyton
gratulations man thank you guys this is
the fighter and a kid we're out hey guys
guest host on Friday the kid today
birdie boy world tour kicks off January
30th and Burlington Vermont we've got a
second show there and it runs in we go
back to the west coast where we're doing
San Jose Sacramento Bakersfield and then
all over it goes till May I hope see you
guys out there I hope you enjoyed the
show thanks
[Laughter]